tras días de aumento de la actividad
sísmica a gigantescas columnas de humo y
cenizas salieron de un volcán situado en
el parque nacional de cumbre vieja
devorando el bosque a su paso poco a
poco la imparable columna de humo se
abrió paso colina abajo y algunas casas
fueron destruidas mira mira mira cómo
cae
los residentes se quedaron atónitos
mientras veían como la lava roja fundida
se disparaba hacia el cielo el volcán
que creían inactivo entró en erupción
por primera vez en 50 años justo antes
de que cumbre vieja liberara su magma
una periodista de televisión estaba a
punto de entrar en directo cuando
[Aplausos]
y más
mientras ríos de lava se derramaban por
la ladera las autoridades emitieron una
orden de evacuación obligatoria para
cuatro pueblos un total de 10.000
personas serán evacuadas de sus hogares
como como mucho miedo
no lo esperaba estábamos avisados pero
no esperaba la verdad que a partir de
esta noche con temblor esta mañana fue
uno grande que tuvo que agarrar a la
tele de la casa
cumbre vieja tuvo una erupción
importante por última vez en 1971 en una
de las regiones más volcánicas de las
islas canarias desde 1430 cuando está
registrada la primera erupción de la
palma